regardez-moi avec le bras robotique je
fais semblant de faire de la moto en
fait c'est un système en procédé de film
avec un robot sur lequel ils ont posé
une caméra ici c'est une caméra de Nikon
et le truc qui est ouf c'est que vous
avez une bécane qui fait un espèce
d'objet en plastique et toi tu es en
train de faire comme situation une vraie
moto en train de te déplacer ça fait
absolument marrer une fois de plus on va
comment les innovations arrivent à nous
payer des trucs pour faire un peu comme
du cinéma voilà tu es à Hollywood tu
tombe Cruise en mission impossible sur
ma bécane un peu sauf qu'à un moment je
me penche du mauvais côté voilà je
voulais vous montrer ça je trouve ça
marrant est-ce que les techniques de
cinoche comme ça ça vous botte ça vous
ne vote pas parce que vous trouvez ça
intéressant moi personnellement c'est un
malgré de le faire d'ailleurs dites pas
vous ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires